[Music]
if someone asks you if you know about
kubernetes you have no problem saying
yes if they ask you to set up and manage
a gke cluster on Google Cloud perhaps it
it's been a while or you are new to
Google Cloud you may not be clear on
some of the actions you need to take
duet AI is here to help let's start by
opening up duet AI from the goo Google
Cloud console
toolbar if you don't see this
icon make sure you've got duet aai
activated on your project and you have
the permissions to use it you could also
use the duet AI chat from within your
IDE of choice let's Jump Right In and
ask how we can run kubernetes on Google
Cloud without having to own management
of notes and the control Pane and here
we have duet ai's
response to run kubernetes on Google
Cloud can use Google kubernetes engine
autopilot mode you can also use GK
managed nodes which are fully managed
kubernetes that are provisioned and
maintained by Google let's continue our
conversation we'd love to standardize
our cluster creation and autopilot using
terraform so let's ask if we can do that
from the response we see that we can we
even get a link or three to dive deeper
we could bookmark these for now as I'd
really like to test GK cluster
creation duet AI chat is an ongoing
conversation as long as it stays in this
session we could also reset our chat by
clicking the reset icon for now we'll
continue on duet AI has recommended gke
in autopilot mode for running kubernetes
in Google Cloud however I'm un familiar
with how this managed kubernetes service
works so let's first test gke in
autopilot mode and have duet AI help us
along H we get a response but there are
some placeholder values for cluster name
region and project ID since I'm already
in the project and I know the cluster
name and region I'll be more specific
with duet AI so I can just copy and
paste the
response okay now let's copy this
g-cloud command into Cloud shell and get
started deploying a sample application
this will take some time after our
cluster has finished provisioning we can
use a test application for further
experimentation Google already has one
called hello- app and we can use du AI
to help us see how it behaves in gke
autopilot let's use Google's test
container image to create a deployment
called hello- server after a few moments
du AI responds and includes the command
let's run it in Cloud
shell now the web server is created but
in order for anyone to get to it we'll
need to provision a load balancer for it
let's ask duet AI how to expose this
deployment on Port 80 with a load
balancer look at that I didn't even tell
the deployment name but it understood
from Context that I wanted hello server
when I said to expose this deployment
finally if we want to see this service
in action we'll need to point our
browser to an IP address let's ask du
aai to help us find it we should get a
response with a command to run in our
terminal let's run it and in a few
minutes we should have an IP address
plugging the IP address into our browser
shows us the hello- server deployment in
action once again let's head into chat
and ask do a I how we can configure time
periods where gke autopilot will not
perform maintenance or upgrades duet AI
responds with information on maintenance
windows and exclusions after reading
this you might realize the off hours of
10: p.m. to 2: a.m. are a great time for
maintenance to be run so let's ask how
to create a daily maintenance window on
our cluster at that time after a few
moments of thinking voila duet AI has
given us a response we could input this
command in our shell to set this up and
feel free but now you are ready to add
duet AI to your infrastructure
Administration tool belt you will also
use it to Aid in deploying and
maintaining your kubernetes clusters on
Google Cloud to find out more ways duet
AI can improve your infrastructure
Administration and other workflows visit
go.go
sl--
overview
[Music]